So here in our show,
we really love trying to make good things happen
for people that we have on the show.
And when the cameras stop rolling,
the story isn't over.
I'm constantly wondering how they've been doing
after we've said goodbye.
And I really mean it when I say let's keep in touch.
So I invited a few of our inspiring guests back today
for a little check-in.
But first,
why don't we have a little refresh
on when they were on the show and what their stories are.
Take a look.
(gentle music)
I love this next story about a dad
who built a no-judgment food pantry on his lawn
for anyone who needed groceries.
And when donations started pouring in,
he had to turn his entire garage into a safe place
for a community in need.
I'd love a bigger space and just help out more people.
Our friends at Conagra Brand believe
that everyone should have access to great and healthy food.
This is from Conagra to you.
Thank you so much, (indistinct).
Thank you, Barney.
Oh my God.
11 year old, Zach Hartman has made it his mission
to give back to those in need
by finding new homes for used books and stuffed animals.
I collected and donated over 65,000 books.
You needed like an extra at $1,900 to reach your goal.
We wanna give you that money.
And do you know what, I'm just gonna do 5,000.
Thank you.
Say hello to Alejandro Diasgranados
from Aiton Elementary School.
My personal mission always has been
to give my students access to a variety of people,
programs, resources, and connections to
and really enhance their learning experience.
We actually reached out to Asus
and they are giving us enough Asus Chromebooks
for every single student and teacher at Aiton Elementary.
I can't even fathom this.
This is crazy.
He saw a burning car on the street
with a mother and her three children inside.
He risked his own life to pull each one of them out.
The mayor wanted to give you this proclamation,
and that's not all, it's Carmelo Anthony.
What?
I want to let you know how inspiring
and courageous you are, man.
You are true, true hero.
So we're gonna hook you on some joint brands march
as small thank you--
No way.
For the big thing that've been doing, man.
We also found out that you're a fan of the Brooklyn Nets.
So we have hooked you all up.
We're getting you season passes.
The players are excited to meet you.
Thank you, Justin.
Thank you so much.
Hello, Monique.
You founded a non-profit dance studio,
serving underprivileged kids.
When I was coming up, we didn't have the extra funds.
So I wanted to make sure that I can offer that
to every youth that I came in contact with.
I just wanna say thank you.
And I'd also like to contribute $10,000.
Oh my God.
Get outta here, Drew.
Don't make me cry on TV, Drew.
Don't do that.
(audience applauding)
Okay, return I'm like.
Returning to the show are a Barney, Zach,
Justin, Alejandro and Monique.
Hi, guys.
Welcome back.
Hello.
Barney.
Drew.
How are you?
How is the food pantry going since we last spoke?
So I'm great.
Thank you again, by the way,
being on your first show, that was such an honor.
I'm still getting our Amazon packages today
from people who saw me on your show.
So thank you.
Yes, it's awesome.
Thank you so much.
I mean we're every other week still we're about 150
to 175 people.
We were up to 300 at one point,
which was mind-blowing and so awesome.
I mean, we're trucking along and trying to grow this thing
and help as many people as possible.
And you are a huge part of that.
So thank you.
That makes me so happy.
And my beautiful friend, Zach and his mom.
Hi, guys.
Hey.
Hi.
How's everything going?
We're really busy.
So I was able to order 50 Zach's packs
and 500 books with the money that you've donated to us.
And I've also donated 2000 books
to a local title one school.
Also I've upcycled 200 stuffed animals,
and I've given them to a--
Humane society.
A humane society in Louisiana
that got hit by one of our most recent hurricanes.
So I've been really busy.
Thank you, Zach and Kim.
Thank you truly.
Justin.
Hi.
I cannot stop thinking about your smile.
How are you?
School was going great for me.
I should be getting my high school diploma by September.
Is it your GED, what is the program?
I actually re-enrolled at the school.
Really?
Justin!
Oh, Justin you're just the greatest.
Now I also wanna check in with our friend, Alejandro,
how are you?
I am doing well.
You know, things have been really exciting since the show,
both current and former students reached out.
So many families really wanted me
to give their deepest thank you for this gift.
And one more cool thing that actually happened
since the show, so that same week,
I was actually surprised with an announcement
that I was named the 2021 DC teacher of the year,
which was exciting.
(audience applauding)
Yay!
I love that.
Thank you so, so much for this.
Well, congratulations, Alejandro.
So well deserved and I'll see you soon.
See you soon, Drew.
Thank you.
And last but not least welcome back, Monique.
I feel like I just saw you the other day.
How's everything going for you and your students?
Oh my God, so much has happened.
So let me start by saying a lot of people were touched
by the episode that we did and we received donations.
We had multiple families reaching out to us,
wanting to sign their kids up for the organization.
Most recently we had the Daytona International Speedway
contact us and asks us if we could perform
during their race week
where the students will be performing in front
of over 100,000 people.
So much has happened.
So many good things.
I'm so glad that we are linked in the chain of your story
and you deserve all of this.
And I am so happy.
I love when a little spark ignites a fire.
That's perfect,
but you're the one who built the whole thing.
Thank you so much, Drew.
No, Monique, thank you.
You are so awesome.
This is the best news in the world.
Thank you, thank you.
Barney, Zach, Justin, Alejandro and Monique,
thank you for the check-in.
We'll talk to you soon.
(upbeat music)